hello and welcome to see you're playing
Super Puma and he place the electrons
defense okay place the classical line
with Bishop g4 me this does not have
such a great reputation nowadays but I'm
probably the one who won't go to edit to
prove why okay so I just don't know I
just in a why but people don't play it
all that much nowadays consider to be a
bit passive so here what's going on um I
was kind of gambling a little bit with
the deep horn okay so i think i'm gonna
gamble one move on I wasn't quite sure
if i have something fantastic in case of
a captcha so here you should normally
just go back him but i don't know if i
want to go back and i think i think i'm
happy with this okay it doesn't even
take that then this was a successful
operation so hmm okay maybe I've for me
look f3h three it's a bit on the crude
side but to be honest i'm getting
checkmated against those the texts are
often might as well try try it myself
those kind of cavemen attacks
yeah i mean i don't think it's so
terrible I've got a good central control
so it's not like a completely fishy idea
okay so here we go hey yo let's go yeah
so 55 m yeah but okay first of all let's
not let's not be too quick so Queen d3
is going f5
g5 from their g5f six probably esta news
I would then queen of three is also good
and let's do it f6 no g6 or that I
didn't expect is that good so if I moved
my bishop pair on nitrogen he basically
has to play a five now right now 19th so
night x g6 is got Bishop a queen Queen
g7 so I'm going to bring in another look
Butchie one yeah i think that the cleve
manitech this is very dangerous
no it gets pretty strong maybe it wasn't
so bad I mean it was certainly a bit of
the crude side but I have c4d for FY I
mean with such a big center you can
cannot be that badly off so once to play
will be seven hmm so I have at five now
so one possibility and 96 takes Queen
takes rook g7 is not yet decisive I need
to knit the bishop I just wonder i can
go bishop see 1 2 a 3 which isn't bad
boy f5
I let square five the only thing that
really concerns me is that he might have
some some kind of counter sacrifice to
end my attack and maybe Bishop h6 first
yeah then we'll be five then it will be
five maybe so okay let's take this 95
something like that maybe
96 now should welcome 96 that should
work where three takes a 597
double-check wins everything pawn takes
Queen takes is made mallets that's the
end of it
black resides Jim probably it was
dangerous so let's let's check check
around here yeah the computer likes
white as well even though g-force may be
a bit much not and then engine likes
white him it is dangerous yeah if it
takes it there's Quincy to 123 made and
the take off the piece a g6 I was
thinking yet to play at six then yeah i
think i will probably take and then this
position i was thinkin queen d 3 how
about f take seems ok for them that was
probably critical g6 I don't believe in
this move a lot I Queen g2 was strong
but what's that bad no I'm playing
mostly engine moves that's good I have I
played all the engine rules which I was
a little bit concerned that something
like that might be possible and now yeah
it doesn't have a good news room Queenie
6 check is always an issue like this but
I always have the check and here ninety
six girls and so on that looks looks
like I played the best moves most of the
time according to the computer at least
the best move so that that was good ok
guys thanks for watching